Opposers, we all know
who the most persecuted group
in America is.
That's right, men.
Did you know a whopping
five percent of U.S. companies
had female CEOs?
Which means that, with the
exception of 95% of the economy,
women control the economy.
(laughter)
This all points to one thing.
Wardrobe lady?
(clears throat)
(laughter)
There's a war on men!
Something ominous is happening
to men in America.
...a war on men.
(laughing)
-NEWSMAN: ...war on men.
-(roaring)
Boom! That's right, men,
there's a war on us.
And not even
the spurriest of bone spurs
will get us out of it.
You see, women have decided
we're the bad guys,
just because we're
"reluctant to change a system"
that benefits us
at their expense.
And now they're hitting us
below the belt,
and slightly to the side.
And-- get your head
out of the gutter,
I'm talking about our wallets.
-Battleground one: money.
-(woman's echoing laughter)
-(loud boom)
-Yes.
You know that fake pay gap
women keep complaining about?
Well, I believe in it now,
because it's hurting men.
There are now seven places
in the U.S.
where women earn more than men.
Seven places!
But I say even one is too many.
Did you know that every time
a woman out-earns a man,
an angel loses his erection
and then punches a wall?
-(laughter, whooping, applause)
-Yeah.
It's true.
And now these greedy women don't
just want to take our money,
they want to be our money.
Check it.
A new bipartisan bill to put
more women on U.S. coins.
Their portraits would appear on
the back side of the coins,
opposite George Washington.
The first design mockups
could arrive in 2020,
the 100th anniversary of women
gaining the right to vote.
How appropriate.
No.
More like non-appropriate.
I can't make heads
or tails of this.
Oh, oh, I'm sorry.
I mean heads or lady heads
of this.
Ugh. Do you see how gross
and oppressive that feels?
This is a huge problem.
And not just because
four girl quarters
will only be worth 79 cents.
It's clear the female vagenda
is trying to use small change
to change the world
as we know it.
So don't tell me, "Relax, man,
it's just a coin."
No, no.
Representation matters, okay.
First, it's our quarters,
then our dollars.
And then young girls
start seeing themselves
represented everywhere.
And pretty soon, I have
to explain to my son, Truck,
that he can't grow up
to be whatever he wants.
Because they put a lady
on a quarter,
and now there's
a more qualified women out there
who also wants to be
a ninja astronaut.
So you better learn to cook
a goddam egg!
It's just not fair!
(applause)
Yes, yes!
But look, women aren't just
coming for our moolah.
They're also coming
for our manhood,
which brings me to
battleground two: penises.
(woman laughing, explosion)
Look what they're doing
with our penises.
Actresses Cate Blanchett
and Sandra Bullock,
-they're both gorgeous women.
-Yes.
-Flawless skin.
They have tried the so-called--
-this is an anatomical
reference-- -(gasps)
the so-called "penis facial."
-Wait, wait.
-It happens to be derived
from the foreskin
of Korean newborns.
Oh, my goodness.
Ugh.
(laughter)
A hard-hitting report from
what I could only assume
is an every day episode
of Good Morning, Belfast.
(laughter)
This is outrageous.
These penis facials go against
the natural order.
I'll say it loud and proud:
penises are only for men
to enjoy.
But now women are using
our dicks to trick us
into thinking they're prettier
than they are.
That is vain.
Women, what have men ever done
to make you think your value
is based on your
physical appearance?
This is clearly
a diabolical plot
to steal our male essence,
our power, our influence,
our ability to grill meat
outdoors.
And don't tell me, "Relax, man,
it's just the tip."
(laughter)
That's how it starts.
First, it's the foreskin facial,
then it's the testicle earrings,
and before you know it,
some witchy woman is wearing
your skin, doing your job,
and woman spreading
all over the bus,
while screaming at you
to smile more.
No, no.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I don't want to smile.
You've taken my skin and my job
and it sucks.
Final battleground:
physical strength.
(woman laughs, explosion)
Look, maybe you're a tough guy.
Maybe you think women are weak.
Well, think again.
The Northeastern ladies
basketball team
was on the way to a, a game,
a big game,
and something horrible happened,
their bus got stuck.
So you know what they did?
They did what women do.
They got out and they started
pushing it,
GIFFORD:
Look at that.
-until it moved. -GIFFORD:
The power of estrogen.
Oh, the power of estrogen.
What is that, the tag line for
Wonder Woman 2?
Kamala Harris'
2020 campaign slogan?
A little known "B" side from
Huey Lewis and the News?
♪ That's the power
of estrogen. ♪
What is it?
But power of estrogen is scaring
the (bleep) out of me.
An not just because I once read
that eating edamame
will give you moobs, no.
This is America.
Men are supposed to be
the strong ones.
Have you seen me open a jar?
(laughs)
Trick question.
If you'd seen me,
we'd already be dating.
But these women, they are
stealing my thunder.
And don't tell me,
"Relax, man.
"It's just an inspiring story
about a women's
basketball team."
No. This is the beginning
of the end.
These women are saying,
"Hey, men,
we don't need you anymore."
Instead of waiting
for some streetwise Hercules
to bail them out,
they Voltroned
into one big Her-cules,
and she's scaring the (bleep)
out of me.
So, men,
let this be a call to you
to join the resistance.
Men, we must stand up
and defend ourselves.
We must be defensive.
Hell, we'll be overly defensive.
Equality is a finite resource,
and women on a shopping spree
to gobble it all up.
So we need to protect
what little we have left,
which is going to be tough,
because it's still
almost everything.
It's so hard.
Stay strong, men.
The fight continues.